welcome to exploring computing
today's video is computer hardware part
one
and overview in this video we're going
to take a look at the basics of computer
hardware
i think a natural place we should start
off with is making sure we're all on
board on exactly what the computer
hardware
is so we have this distinction in
computing between
the hardware which is the physical
device and the software
and i think everybody understands at
some instinctual level that
the software are these programs that we
add to the computer
and so say for example i find out that i
need to record
all of the lectures for this quarter i
might decide
oh i heard premiere pro is a really
great video editing program i should go
ahead and get a copy
of that and so i can go ahead and
purchase it and install it on my
computer
so that i think we all understand that
but actually
there's a lot that's integral to our
computer or we think it's integral to
our computer that actually isn't part of
the computer hardware so
i can buy a macbook pro from the store
and i naturally think the fact that it's
a macintosh is
naturally part of the computer but it
actually turns out i can take that
macbook pro
computer and i can actually replace the
system software
with windows so suppose i start working
in a lab and it turns out that that lab
requires me to use some software and i
can't run it on my macintosh
because it doesn't run on mac os i can
actually replace
mac os with microsoft windows on my
macbook pro hardware
and that's because the operating system
is
actually software as well so those are
the instructions that we think of
as being an integral part of the
computer and they're actually
not they're just instructions running on
the hardware
similarly if i decided i wanted to
take my laptop here and turn it into a
some sort of a server and i wanted to
get
linux software for it i can go ahead and
replace mac os with
linux and again that's because the
system software
is replaceable and that is something a
set of instructions that
runs on top of the hardware so we have
this distinction with software and
hardware
and we have a distinction between
application software
and system software and we're going to
take a closer look at
the system software and the operating
system in another lecture all right
let's start let's focus on the hardware
itself
we distinguish between three main
categories of hardware we have
processing
which is primarily the central
processing unit and then
we have memory which consists of two
types of
memory there's primary memory and
secondary memory
where primary memory is colloquially
thought of as ram
although it turns out there's a little
bit more to it than just the ram
and the secondary memory are things like
the solid state drive
the hard drive flash memory and
basically the distinction between the
primary memory and the secondary
memory is the primary memory is what we
refer to as volatile so the power goes
out
i lose all the information in the
primary memory the secondary memory is
non-volatile
which means even if i completely lose
power the information
in secondary memory is still fine the
other main distinction is
primary memory is much much faster than
secondary memory because you may wonder
why don't we just use this
non-volatile memory well the answer is
because it's much slower
now i also should highlight here that
nowadays this distinctionally
primary and secondary memory or more
pointedly
volatile versus non-volatile memory is a
little bit hidden because we're used to
being able to
put our laptops or cell phones or
tablets to sleep
and turn them on later and everything's
still there exactly as it was before
and it turns out that when we put a
computer to sleep
the main memory is still getting a
little bit of trickle charge of
electricity if the battery goes out
completely
you're going to lose all the information
so in addition to processing
and memory there's also input output and
that includes things like
the obvious the display the keyboard
the mouse if you've got one and it also
includes external devices like printers
and scanners
i should also mention that while i'm
primarily going to be focusing here on
laptops and desktops
smartphones and tablets work almost
exactly the same they have the exact
same distinction between primary memory
and secondary memory
they've got that processor with a
central processing unit and
modern smartphones and tablets also have
a graphics processing unit
and then finally there's something in
terms of input output
i suppose in some sense that the display
is acting as both
an output and an input for smartphones
and tablets but in addition to these
types of computers there's also what are
referred to as embedded
computers or embedded systems and
embedded computers are the computers
that
that run inside of things like our our
car so you know our car has computers
that are tracking
different pieces of input like how hot
is the engine
you know how much fuel do i have how
hard is the user pressing on the gas
pedal
these are the sorts of inputs that come
into the embedded computer that's inside
of your car and the outputs would be
things like
you know how much flow of gasoline
should i let into the engine so
there's lots and lots of different
computers other than just
the desktops the laptops the smartphones
and
and our tablets okay so what i'm going
to do now is
we've gone over processing with a
central processing unit and our graphics
processing unit
we've gone over our memory with the
primary and secondary memory
and what i want to do now is see how
these different components kind of play
out
when i'm carrying out some basic
computing tasks so let's start off with
i'm going to install an application so i
mentioned before hey i need to get a
hold of premiere pro so what is what is
that all going to involve
well premiere pro consists of a bunch of
different instructions
and so i need to get a hold those
instructions and get them onto my
computer
so i'm going to go ahead and download a
copy of those instructions
and i'm going to install on my computer
now it turns out a lot of times when i'm
installing these
programs the programs that i'm actually
getting over the internet or sometimes
when i'm buying a cd-rom or dvd
a copy of a program it's actually those
programs are actually
compressed so we talked about
compression last week
particularly if you're installing over
the internet but again also sometimes
when you're installing from a dvd or cd
the files are compressed in order to
allow it to transfer through the
internet uh
you know taking less space which makes
things cheaper for whoever's paying to
uh serve up those files
so when they come over to your computer
they do need to be decompressed
sometimes there's a two-step process
it's like
actually decompresses all the files onto
your hard drive
and then after they've been decreased
you have to run an additional
installation program so that's what's
going on with that
um so i need to get the files
i need to get the installation files
onto my computer and i need to
decompress them and get the instructions
onto my computer
those instructions since they're things
that i want to have stick around
even when the power on my computer goes
off therefore those instructions need to
go
on my secondary memory device whether
it's the solid state drive or hard disk
ultimately the instructions after i'm
done installing are going to be on that
secondary memory device
now when i run an application what
happens is
the instructions need to be copied into
main memory because it turns out the
central processing unit
cannot access things directly on the
hard disk
or the solid state drive so if my
program is actually going to execute as
opposed to the program is just installed
on my computer and i'm not actually
running it
if it's installed on my computer i'm not
actually running it then the
instructions are on the hard disk or
this
ssd when i actually double click on that
or i tap on it on my cell phone and it
starts up the instructions are going to
get
copied from the solid state drive or the
hard disk they're going to get copied
into main memory where they can actually
get access by the cpu
now as far as documents go like let's
say
i'm i decided i wanted to open up a
microsoft word document
those documents when i'm not accessing
them directly from a program they're
going to also sit in that secondary
memory device because
i want to keep my introduction to
humanities paper i want to keep that
around
after the computer turns off if the
computer turns off and loses power
i still want to have my i hum paper so
that needs to be on this the secondary
memory device
now when i actually start editing that
paper again
the cpu cannot access things directly
from
the secondary memory device so the ins
all the the contents of
my paper need to get copied into main
memory so
when i'm interacting with it when i'm
manipulating it's in main memory
when i go ahead and save it it copies
everything from main memory it's
copies into secondary storage so we do
need to understand this distinction
between the main memory
and the secondary storage now one
question that comes up
is how do i know you know my computer's
not
acting as quickly as i'd like
what what should i do about it do i need
more main memory or do i need more
secondary storage
well in general you're gonna need more
secondary storage if you're storing a
lot of
data so let's say for example um
you decide you want to be a v logger so
you're gonna you're gonna do
i guess they're called vloggers you want
let's just say you decide you can become
a vlogger
you're gonna have a whole bunch of video
that video is gonna take a lot
a lot of space now it's not like you're
gonna have all that video
playing at the same time if you're
playing all that video at the same time
then it all needs to be in main memory
but you're not playing it all at the
same time
you you create and edit one of them you
of course you don't want to lose it so
you need to store it you create and add
another one
and so if you have lots of video files
you need more secondary storage
whether it's you're going to need a
bigger ssd or you've got so much stuff
that turns out it's cheaper to buy
storage and hard disks so you go ahead
and buy hard disks and storing your hard
disk
on the other hand if you're running lots
and lots of programs at once
and i see lots and lots of students to
do this if you're running a whole bunch
of programs at once
then you need to get more main memory
so you know if you can double your main
memory
you're going to find that your programs
are running a lot more efficiently
because
um basically there's a limit to how many
programs can be
main memory at once and there's a system
called virtual memory which we'll talk
about a little bit later
where uh you know if you've got too many
programs to fit into main memory it can
the computer can still kind of go but
it's going using virtual memory and
that's going to really slow things down
and a lot of students run way too many
programs for the amount of main memory
they have
and it really hurts their performance